-Dans une autre vie,
elle a été une pro de la com,
mais en politique,
ne comptez pas sur elle
pour faire des coups d'éclat.
Mon invitée assume un style
à la fois sérieux et plutôt discret.
Générique
...
Bonjour, Maud Gatel.
-Bonjour.
-Vous êtes députée MoDem
de Paris, mais votre engagement
politique a d'abord été marqué
par une passion
pour l'Europe
qui remonte à loin.
Elle remonte à ça.
Expliquez-nous.
-Alors c'est l'album Panini
que ma maman m'a offert
quand j'étais très jeune.
Je pense que j'avais 9, 10 ans.
Parce que j'ai développé
assez tôt une passion
pour l'Europe en construction,
je pense en lien avec la chute
du Mur qui m'avait marquée.
-J'allais vous demander :
si c'était un album de foot,
vous seriez footballeuse ?
Mais la passion pour l'Europe
a précédé l'album.
-Oui, en tout cas, c'est comme ça
que je me souviens des choses.
C'est vrai que j'avais
été très marquée
par cette réconciliation
des peuples,
qui avait, chez moi,
eu beaucoup,
beaucoup d'échos.
-Et de fil en aiguille,
c'est ce qui vous a amenée
à vous intéresser
à la politique très jeune ?
-C'est vraiment mon engagement.
L'engagement européen,
c'est celui qui demeure.
J'avais un engagement
pour l'environnement,
aussi, très, très jeune.
Je me passionnais déjà
pour la question des déchets
et du recyclage, et finalement,
j'ai mes deux piliers :
l'environnement et l'Europe.
-Et la politique en général,
parce que je crois
que dès l'âge de 9 ans,
vous vous êtes passionnée
pour la présidentielle de 1988 :
François Mitterrand
face à Jacques Chirac.
Ca a continué pour vous
au collège et au lycée,
mais vous dites
que la politique, pour vous,
c'était un spectacle,
et que vous ne vous imaginez
pas forcément monter sur scène
pour être une actrice
de ce spectacle.
Pourquoi ?
-Je considérais que la politique,
c'était pas pour moi.
C'était un intérêt très fort.
Effectivement, je m'intéressais
beaucoup à l'actualité.
Je me souviens très bien
de ces images,
mais je voyais ça comme
quelque chose d'extérieur à moi.
Je n'étais que spectatrice
et non pas actrice.
-C'était une forme d'autocensure,
liée, je sais pas,
à votre environnement social ?
-C'était peut-être
une autocensure, en tout cas,
je ne voyais pas le chemin
pour moi, pour y prendre part.
-Vous pensez que c'est
encore valable pour les jeunes,
cette idée que la politique
est réservée à une certaine
catégorie de la population ?
-Oui, et je pense
qu'il y a beaucoup d'autocensure,
y compris aujourd'hui.
C'est la raison pour laquelle
je travaille, justement,
à ouvrir la politique
sur la société,
pour donner l'envie, le goût,
mais surtout les clés
pour celles et ceux qui veulent
s'engager ou qui le sont déjà.
-Vous faites quoi, concrètement ?
-C'est un peu de la politique
hors les murs.
C'est montrer qu'il y a
différentes formes d'engagement
qui peuvent prendre
une forme politique
- c'est pas à la place -
mais une forme politique
et que ce milieu n'est pas fermé,
pas réservé à quelques-uns,
mais qu'il est
le plus ouvert possible,
et je travaille
à ce qu'il le soit encore davantage.
-Vous avez fait les études
dont vous rêviez :
Sciences Po à Bordeaux.
Peu après, vous avez décroché
un stage auprès de Michel Barnier
à la Commission européenne,
puis Marielle de Sarnez
vous a embauchée
comme collaboratrice
au Parlement européen.
Quel souvenir
est-ce que vous gardez
de ces 7 années passées
avec Marielle de Sarnez ?
-Je garde...
D'abord, elle m'a beaucoup,
beaucoup appris :
la rigueur,
toujours le souci du détail,
et puis je garde aussi...
Je dis souvent
que je suis un bébé
du Parlement européen :
j'ai été élevée à cette culture
du compromis, du travail ensemble,
de travailler sur des majorités
autour de projets communs,
et c'est vrai que parfois,
j'inspirerais
à ce que l'Assemblée nationale
s'inspire
bien davantage des pratiques
du Parlement européen.
-Marielle de Sarnez n'était pas
n'importe qui chez les centristes :
vice-présidente du MoDem,
longtemps bras droit
de François Bayrou.
Elle a été votre mentor,
en politique ?
-Elle a totalement été mon mentor.
-C'était une figure
qui était très respectée,
mais qui avait aussi
la réputation
d'être assez exigeante.
-Très exigeante, on peut le dire.
-C'était parfois compliqué ?
-Elle savait absolument
ce qu'elle voulait,
et elle avait la même exigence
pour les autres
qu'elle avait à l'égard d'elle-même,
et effectivement,
le niveau était très élevé,
mais je pense que quiconque
l'a croisée au cours
de sa carrière
de femme politique
lui reconnaît à la fois
cette rigueur,
cette exigence pour elle-même
avant d'être exigeante
pour les autres.
-Au bout de 7 ans
avec de Marielle de Sarnez,
vous avez tourné la page
du Parlement européen
pour vous lancer
dans une carrière
dans la communication,
chez Tilder puis chez TBWA,
qui sont des références
dans le secteur.
Vous donniez des conseils
à des grands patrons
ou à des organismes publics.
On est loin de la politique
et de ce que vous faisiez avant.
Pourquoi ce choix-là ?
Vous aviez envie de changer d'air ?
-Non, en fait, c'est la politique
qui m'a attrapée à un moment
où je ne m'attendais pas du tout
à avoir cette opportunité.
J'ai énormément appris
et apprécié ces 7 années
passées à côté
de Marielle de Sarnez,
mais j'ai toujours voulu
avoir un vrai métier.
-C'est-à-dire ?
Gagner votre vie
indépendamment de la politique ?
-Absolument. D'ailleurs,
je considérais
que c'était compliqué
d'être à la fois payée
par la politique comme salarié,
et élue. J'aspirais,
effectivement,
à me présenter à des élections,
et j'ai toujours beaucoup apprécié
la communication et je pense
qu'on peut faire de grandes choses
avec les organisations,
les entreprises,
et je pense avoir aussi
servi l'intérêt général
à travers mon engagement auprès
de grands dirigeants d'entreprise.
-En parallèle de la com, vous êtes
restée engagée en politique,
mais vous êtes passée
au niveau local.
Vous avez été élue
conseillère de Paris.
Vous avez pris la tête
du MoDem à Paris.
J'ai même lu
que vous n'excluiez pas
de vous présenter
comme candidate
à la mairie de Paris
plus tard.
-J'aime infiniment cette ville
qui m'a adoptée
il y a 25 ans, maintenant,
et je souffre beaucoup
de voir se dégrader
notre patrimoine,
qu'il soit architectural, végétal,
et de voir que chaque année
il y a 12 000 Parisiens
qui quittent la ville,
parce qu'ils aspirent
à autre chose, et je pense
qu'on a besoin
d'une grande ambition pour Paris.
Je continuerai à la porter
et prendrai ma part aux changements
que je souhaite.
-Vous avez de grandes ambitions
politiques, c'est légitime.
Vous occupez des fonctions
importantes : secrétaire générale
du MoDem, mais vous êtes
très discrète dans les médias.
Pour une pro de la com',
ça peut surprendre.
Pourquoi cette discrétion ?
-C'est pas une discrétion voulue,
c'est une discrétion
qui, finalement,
est le fait
de beaucoup de choses à faire
et d'un emploi du temps chargé,
mais ça n'est pas revendiqué.
-Vous ne réservez pas
une place dans votre agenda
aux médias ?
-Alors, pas suffisamment,
en tout cas.
Je compte bien...
-Vous aimez pas aller
sur un plateau télé...
-Si,
j'aime bien ça
pour aller défendre des convictions.
J'aime beaucoup, effectivement,
les sujets de fond.
J'aime pouvoir débattre
sur des idées
et je devrais faire un peu plus
de place dans mon agenda
aux sollicitations médias.
-Marielle de Sarnez est revenue
dans votre vie en 2017.
Aux législatives,
elle vous a proposé d'être
sa suppléante,
à l'occasion de ce scrutin.
Vous avez dit non deux fois,
puis oui, la troisième fois.
Pourquoi avoir refusé ?
-Elle m'a proposé,
parce que j'étais présidente
du MoDem Paris
et j'avais été candidate
sur cette circonscription
cinq ans auparavant,
mais moi, j'aspirais à poursuivre
ma carrière professionnelle.
Elle avait...
C'était à la suite
de l'élection
d'Emmanuel Macron.
Elle allait prendre
de grandes responsabilités.
C'était pas, pour moi,
le moment,
mais Marielle, on lui résistait
jamais longtemps
et j'ai fini,
oui,
par lui dire oui.
-Marielle de Sarnez est décédée
d'une leucémie foudroyante
en janvier 2021.
Il y a eu, évidemment,
le choc, l'émotion,
et très vite, le moment du choix
pour vous, qui étiez sa suppléante.
En quelques jours,
vous avez dû décider,
soit de siéger
à l'Assemblée, en tant que députée,
soit de rester
dans la communication
où vous étiez promise
à une carrière brillante.
Ca a été un choix difficile à faire,
pour vous ?
-Ca a été un moment d'abord
très difficile,
parce que quand vous perdez
quelqu'un d'aussi important
pour votre famille politique
et pour vous-même, c'est difficile.
Il y a pas pire manière
d'entrer à l'Assemblée
que d'entrer
à l'Assemblée nationale
à la suite du décès de la personne
qui vous a tout appris.
Le choix a été compliqué,
mais il s'est finalement
assez rapidement imposé,
dans la mesure où je considérais
qu'il y avait une suite
à donner au parcours
de Marielle
et que mon engagement politique
pouvait aussi
prendre cette forme-là.
-Vous avez fait vos débuts
à l'Assemblée
dans des conditions difficiles
liées d'abord
au décès de Marielle de Sarnez,
mais c'est aussi
que vous avez dû monter
dans un train en marche
sur une législature engagée
depuis trois ans.
Comment ça se passe,
concrètement,
quand on débarque comme ça,
alors que tout le monde est rodé ?
-Quatre ans, même.
-Quatre ans, oui.
-On essaie
de se faire sa place
en restant
sur ses propres fondamentaux.
J'ai eu la chance d'être
très bien accueillie
par mon groupe
et par Jean-Louis Bourlanges,
président de la commission
des Affaires étrangères,
qui m'a confié un rapport
qui avait été souhaité
par Marielle de Sarnez
sur l'autonomie stratégique
de l'Union Européenne,
qui est effectivement
un domaine de compétences
et une passion pour moi,
donc je me suis...
J'ai fait ma place aussi
sur un sujet que je connaissais bien
et qui m'intéressait beaucoup.
-Vous avez été réélue en faisant
campagne sur votre propre nom,
puis en tant que suppléante.
Vous menez de front
trois engagements :
députée, présidente
du groupe MoDem
au conseil de Paris
et secrétaire générale du MoDem.
Vous qui vouliez garder
un travail pour ne pas vivre
de la politique,
c'est un peu raté, là.
-C'est un peu raté, effectivement,
c'est un peu raté,
mais c'est le moment.
J'ai aussi vraiment envie
de m'engager complètement.
Quand j'essaie de faire les choses,
je les fais à fond.
Ca demande, oui,
une organisation assez militaire,
pour faire en sorte
de mener à bien ces trois missions
qui me tiennent toutes très à coeur.
-On va passer à notre quiz
à présent.
Vous allez devoir compléter
les phrases que je vais
vous proposer.
Vous avez droit à un quiz
spécial pro de la com'.
Voilà, c'est comme ça.
Vous êtes prête ?
C'est parti.
"Pour déstabiliser Rachida Dati
"dans un débat, il faut..."
-Il faut...
Euh...
C'est pas si compliqué.
-Ah oui ?
-Oui.
-Vous l'avez fait ?
-Elle a
une incroyable répartie,
mais on peut la déstabiliser.
-Comment ?
-En rappelant
des prises de position
passées de sa part.
-"En com', les députés
"devraient
prendre exemple sur..."
-Sur la technique de com',
malheureusement,
sur La France Insoumise.
Sur la forme,
pas le fond.
-Il y a
une performance
dans ce domaine ?
-Qui est ancienne, qui remonte
à extrêmement longtemps,
mais la création de ces communautés
qui datent de 2012, aujourd'hui,
on voit...
-Leur présence
sur les réseaux sociaux ?
-Le travail mené
depuis longtemps
porte ses fruits
aujourd'hui.
-"Pour s'imposer en politique,
Maud Gatel devrait..."
Donc là, c'est la conseillère com'
face à Maud Gatel.
-Donner plus de temps
dans son agenda
aux médias.
-Ah,
vous le reconnaissez.
Une dernière question pour finir.
Je m'adresse à nouveau
à la pro de la com'.
Quel conseil
vous êtes-vous donné
avant de venir ici ?
-Euh...
D'essayer de répondre
le plus...
De manière
la plus courte possible.
-Merci beaucoup,
Maud Gatel,
d'être venue.
-Merci à vous.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA